hello Chris you are not gonna believe
this what it's unthinkable what damn you
Disney has released a new trailer for
rogue one whoa you know what you must do
I must immediately upload my review of
this trailer without much planning or
thought hoping that every word out of my
mouth is gold despite being unplanned I
will then put a click baby thumbnail
hoping that people click on my video
thinking it's just a trailer despite the
fact that everyone knows I'm going to
like this trailer anyway let's do this
shit well guys they released a new
trailer for Star Wars rogue one I know I
know
hey hey I'm just the messenger calm down
three
well jokes aside guys in December 16th
please come so I can't take this anymore
the possibly but unconfirmed final
trailer for Rwanda buta day and I
watched it and of course it looks great
I mean every trailer so far has look
good so me sitting here saying this
looks good isn't really that much of
news I mean everyone pretty much
expected that out of me already because
I'm a big star Wars fan but let's talk
about what looks really special in this
trailer and for me I was extremely
excited to finally get a look at Mads
Mikkelsen he's one of my favorite actors
I love that guy and I can't wait to see
what he does in this movie so apparently
in row 1 he plays the father of jyn erso
who was in some way integral to the
development of the Death Star that tells
us a lot maybe a little more than I
necessarily needed to know from a
writing standpoint that's really good
for jyn erso scare achter because she's
the one sent to destroy this thing but
her father was integral in building it
and he doesn't exactly seem too proud of
that in this trailer so that's really
gonna give her some really good
background in character depth as well as
give Mads Mikkelsen a really fun
character to play and I really like that
aspect of this trailer and I'm hoping
that that shines true emotionally in the
film it's also of course great to see
some more looks at Darth Vader although
I was hoping for a line or two but I
don't really need that I just want it
because we're gonna see the movie in a
couple months anyway and I will
hopefully get a lot of Gareth Edwards
giving me darth vader and not cutting
away every time darth vader appears
another image in this trailer that I
thought was really cool was this fallen
image of this Jedi statue of some kind
this ruins of what looked like a Jedi
warrior and that tells us that time has
passed which we of course already know
because we understand this timeline it's
been this way since 70s and 80s we know
what this timeline is but it's cool to
see a planet that has the ruins of a
Jedi statue and I love shots like that
that tell the story without having to
tell the story visual storytelling and
I'm hoping as I said this is all just
hope a rebellion bill
hope cuz that's all I can really do is
hope in the end a trailer is just a
trailer you can make a great trailer out
of an OK film so naturally I'm gonna sit
here and tell you that I hope that's not
the case because I've experienced movies
that look this good that end up just
being a very good looking movie that
made a fantastic trailer now this is
nothing new but I gotta say these
effects really do look marvelous I
hesitate to say they might actually look
better than force awakens which also had
fantastic special effects obviously and
I recoil a little bit at saying that
simply because we're seeing one to two
second images of these things in the
trailer and so when we see the film and
and see it all hopefully seamlessly
melded together I can't wait to see what
these effects look like in the movie
because they look amazing in this
trailer but what I appreciate the most
of the tone of this trailer in
particular as well as the other two but
but mostly this one because we finally
do get a touch of emotion and sort of a
hint of depth underneath some of these
characters this trailer is sending this
will be an emotionally powerful
experience not just a fun Star Wars
movie and I think that's really
impressive for a lot of people to just
want ah excuse me we already know that
they get the plans so your movie's gonna
suck
yeah I make movies too you know it seems
like they know they can't just make a
action-adventure movie about getting the
Death Star plans because we know that
the rebels get the Death Star plans and
so they're adding a lot of real emotion
to this movie and that's what's gonna
hook us and that's what I'm excited to
see what did you guys think of the
robo-one trailer I of course liked it it
looks great I can't wait to see the film
let me know below what you thought of
the new trailer guys thank you so much
as always for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes I've got to go tell some
more people about this Star Wars rogue
one trailer there's a new trailer for
Star Wars rogue one see there's a new
trailer for Star Wars drag one don't you
care don't you care don't you care about
the Star Wars trailer don't you what's
wrong with you see tell the people that
Star Wars guys thanks for watching this
do check out my friend Matt Brando his
channel he has amazing reviews he helped
me in the intro of this he is awesome
very good quality content definitely
worth your time